[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing Fact one of the greatest proofs
for the supernatural nature of the Bible
is the Jewish people and the nation of
Israel consider no other people in
history have been driven from their
native land three times over a period of
20600 years maintained their unique
language religion and identity and then
repossessed their Homeland in 1660 BC
Jacob and his tribe were driven from
Canaan to Egypt by a famine then 250
years later Joshua LED them back into
their
inheritance afterward in 586 BC the Jews
were conquered by the Babylonians the
city of Jerusalem the temple were burnt
and then they were carried off to
Babylon for 70 years but then under the
Persian Empire they returned to Israel
and rebuilt the temple in the city in 30
ad Jesus foretold the temple would again
be destroyed and Jerusalem burned in 40
years and it happened right on schedule
in 70 AD the Romans burned and destroyed
the city and the temple for the next
1900 years the Jewish people people were
scattered around Europe and the world
until 1948 when Israel became an
independent state in its native land
this is just an amazing example of how
God has had his hand over this unique
people through history and you might be
surprised to learn Pastor Ross even
though Israel has their own country 30%
of the Jews in the world 16 million Jews
are in Israel but over 51% are in the
United States of America that's right
Pastor I talking before we went on the
air and you mentioned that there's
really two strongholds where Jews find
themselves today of course Israel and
the United States and the United States
is more Jews and then just sort of a a
smattering here and there in other
countries Europe and some other places
but it really seems that the Jewish
people being dispersed through these
different nations for almost whatever
almost 2,000 years less than that 1900
years and yet been able to come back to
their same land having their same
capital city after such a long period of
time he's rather remarkable it's amazing
they survived because not just during
the Nazi regime but through history
there have been a lot of efforts to just
annihilate them and yet they've remained
a distinct people and probably the
central reason for that was the
scriptures uh the scriptures are one
reason they contined to thrive because
they would always teach their young
people to read so they did well in
education and high offices and finances
as well and it helped him Main main
their identity because their whole
culture was based on the scriptures and
so and even for us as Christians we are
in a sense spiritual Israel it's what
gives us our freedom and our identity
where we are Christianity has thrived
and become a world religion and it's
again because of the scriptures and we
have a book that talks about this and
some of these other amazing facts that
we'll offer any of our viewers tonight
and oh you know I should probably read
something I think we had a scripture all
queued up and I I wanted to make sure
and share this with people I mentioned a
prophecy of Jesus where he talked about
U predicting the fall of Jerusalem if
you look in the Book of Luke
21:20 Jesus said but when you see
Jerusalem surrounded by armies then know
that its desolation is near then let
those who are in Judea flee to the
mountains let those who are in the midst
of her depart and let those who are in
the country enter her for these are the
days of vengeance that all things that
are written may be fulfilled and woe to
those that are pregnant and those that
are nursing babies in those days for
there'll be great distress in the land
and wrath upon the people and they will
fall by the edge of the sword and be led
away captive into all nations and
Jerusalem would be trampled down by the
Gentiles until the times of the Gentiles
are fulfilled and all of this vividly
came to pass that Christ had foretold
and then God again brought them back to
their land
so it's just an amazing I think evidence
of the dependability of Prophecy and if
you wonder about the truth of the Bible
just look at the history of the Jewish
Nation it's only Supernatural that
they've survived any other country when
it's been conquered dispersed they're
absorbed they lose their identity they
intermarry and they disappear but the
Jews have just continued to persevere
through history it's incredible and we
have a book the book is called uh SP
Israel what does the Bible say about
Israel both literal Israel of course the
Bible has a lot to say about that but
what about spiritual Israel that you
read about in the New Testament we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
ask the number is
6747 that is our resource phone line you
can also dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then ask for the book by name it's
called spiritual Israel we'll be happy
to send it to anyone here in the US and
in Canada if you're outside of North
America you can just go to our website
just amazingfacts.org and you'll be able
to read the book there again it's called
spiritual Israel the number is 800
83567 47 that is the resource phone line
and one more number we'll give you this
is the the phone line to our studio it's
8463 7297 if you have a Bible question
you can call and ask again it's 800-
46372 97 all right I think we're ready
to go to the phones but Pastor before we
go let's stop with prayer dear father
once again we are grateful for the
opportunity to be able to open up your
word and study and Lord as we always do
we want to invite the Holy Spirit to be
with us to guide us here in the studio
and be with those who are listening
wherever they might be and lead us to a
clearer understanding of what the Bible
says and teaches in jesus' name amen
amen first caller this evening is Gary
listening in Illinois Gary welcome to
the
program thank you uh it seems that
Malachi 4 is a good chapter for these
times it's starts out with or behold the
day is coming it shall burn like an oven
they're talking about planet Earth MH
and but my question specifically is
verse five uh behold I will send you
Elijah the prophet before the great and
Dreadful day of the Lord so is the
Elijah they're talking about Malachi the
same one who had the problem with the
priests of veil and how is he coming is
he coming like reincarnating or or how's
he how's he going to come and
uh how we going to know him yeah great
question um first of all it's not a
reincarnation if you read the story of
Elijah before he went to heaven God
brought him to heaven in a fiery Chariot
he had an apprentice named
Elisha and the Bible says that Elisha
prayed that the spirit of Elijah in a
double portion would fall on him meaning
that Holy Spirit the spirit of Revival
God doesn't you know transfer Souls from
one body to the next and when Elijah
went to to Heaven it says the spirit of
Elijah fell on Elisha then you go to the
New Testament and you look in the Gospel
of Luke 1 when the angel appeared to the
father of John the Baptist to let them
know they're going to have a baby he
said that the baby would go before the
Messiah in the spirit and power of
Elijah so when it talks about I'll send
you Elijah an individual would come that
how would have the same spiritual power
of Elijah and that was in first part
John the Baptist I think it's Matthew 11
Jesus said if you can receive it John
the Baptist is Elijah that was to come
but Jesus also said Elijah has come and
he will come because the prophecy in
Malachi said I'll send you Elijah the
prophet before the great and terrible
day of the Lord so before the second
coming um there is going to be either an
individual or a message again that will
go in the spirit and the power of Elijah
and like John the Baptist so hope that
made sense um you know I I think I I
have an article if you look at the
Amazing Facts website it's talk talks
about the spirit of Elijah and if you
search Doug Bachelor where and the
spirit of Elijah you'll probably find
that just looking through Google thanks
so much Gary appreciate your call next
caller that we have is Stephen listening
in Florida Stephen welcome to Bible
answers live hello how are you doing
doing great thank you for
calling yes I'm doing great as well I
have Christ above all powers amen and
your question
tonight yes my question today is what
did they wash their robes with in the
Book of Revelation and what is that all
about yeah it talks about and they've
washed their robes and made them white
in the blood of the lamb now you and I
would typically not use blood to wash a
white clothes uh this is a symbol it's
through the blood of Christ that we are
washed washed from sin and Pastor Ross
might have a comment on that yeah
Revelation 7:14 it's really a
description of God's people in the last
days here and it talks about those who
washed their robes made them white in
the blood of the Lamb meaning those who
have received and accepted Christ
sacrifice and Pastor D you know it's
important to remember that there's two
parts to the sacrifice of Christ is not
only forgiveness which is very important
but there is also the power of Christ
working in us through the spirit to
bring Deliverance to give victory over
sin so you have justification
sanctification so when it talks about
robes in the Bible it's talking about
character those who by faith have
received Christ's forgiveness and
received Christ's righteousness he
Spirit working within them they've
washed their robes made them white in
the blood of the Lamb yep very good I
hope that helps a little bit and um you
know we have a a gift book that talks
about the riches of his grace that talks
about how everyone can experience that
cleansing from the blood blood of Christ
to receive the book just call 8835 6747
that is our resource phone line you can
ask for the book it's called The Riches
of his grace there's another way you can
get it you can get a digital copy right
away dial pound 250 on your smartphone
say Bible aners live and then you can
also ask for the book it's called The
Riches of his grace and you can go to
the Amazing Facts website if you're
outside of North America and you can
read it there you know I was looking for
a verse also while you were sharing and
it's in Romans 5:9 where Paul says much
more than having now been justified by
his blood we shall be saved from wrath
through him so that was one of the many
verses I think that talks about that
thanks so much Stephen we appreciate it
we've got Jerry listening in Texas Jerry
welcome to the
program hey guys thank you uh I was
reading my Bible this morning and
listening how where that Jesus that let
the blind man that he healed and U the
Christ came later on to reassure him and
show him that it was Christ but in
finishing the chapter how many outer
sanctuaries were there to the um God's
Temple referred to as Solomon's Temple
because when the people came from the
East uh some of jesus' disciples had to
go into the uh outer place where Jesus
was then Jesus went to meet the kings of
the why I was doesn't refer to him as
kings of the East but to re to meet the
men from the East come yes that came to
praise him yeah the um and I you're not
going to find this probably in the Old
Testament I don't think so but by the
time of Christ they they had always had
what they call the courtyard of the
women uh because the men and women would
sep worship separately um they had a
courtyard that only the priests could go
into when they were offering sacrifice
but there was an outer Court where the
people could gather but by the time of
Christ because they were occupied by the
Romans they developed what they call the
the court of the Gentiles there was a
place where Gentiles could come and so
when Jesus went out to speak with the
Greeks that I think it was Philip or
Andrew said that U were looking for him
that he went out probably to that court
of the Gentiles is that your
understanding yeah absolutely you know
it's interesting Pastor you mentioned
that archaeological finds have actually
discovered some stone that was inscribed
by the lettering which sort of was the
mark between the court of the Gentiles
and the court of the Jews and if you
pass that stone that had a very clear
description it was on Pains of death if
you pass that and you were a gentile
into the court of the Jews you were
taking your life in your hands so at
least the Greeks they came right up to
that particular spot they could go no
further and so they sent a message into
Jesus who was inside and he came out to
meet them yeah remember what happened to
Paul when they accused him of bringing
Gentiles into the right they nearly kill
him right thanks you appreciate your
question Jerry Marian is listening in
Canada Marian welcome to the program
thank you pastors I have a scripture uh
1 Corinthians 15 and 29 now if there is
no Resurrection what will those do who
are baptized for the dead if the dead
are not raised at all why are people
baptized for them does this mean we were
supposed to be being baptized for dead
relatives or other people or yeah I'll
I'll do my best to explain that this is
a this is a difficult verse and the
reason is because uh while the
scriptures are perfectly inspired
translators had to decide sometimes
where to put the punctuation and if you
punctuate this verse in the wrong way it
gives a very wrong impression nothing
else in the Bible says that we could get
baptized in behalf of people that are
dead and then maybe they'll be saved
people are not saved by the baptism of
somebody else the Bible says it's
appointed unto man once to die that's
the Hebrews I forget the verse pointed
unto man once to die and after this the
Judgment so after you die is you your
destiny is locked as in the parable of
the rich man and Lazarus there's a great
Gulf fixed there's no changing teams
once you die that verse Hebrews 9:27 the
one you quoted yeah so let me read this
verse the way it should be read if it's
punctuated clearly Paul is discussing
the resurrection with the people in
Corinth and in chapter 15 he spends a
lot of time talking about it and he says
otherwise what will they do who are
baptized comma for the dead comma if the
dead do not rise at all comma why then
are they baptized question mark for the
dead question mark he's saying if the
dead don't rise why do the Believers
even get baptized they getting baptized
for the dead and Paul's asking it as a
rhetorical question he's not asking them
to be baptized for the dead and we don't
believe that the Corinthians were being
baptized for the dead he's just saying
if there's no Resurrection then why do
people get baptized they doing it for
the Dead He's sort of saying it with
tongue and cheek um because they think
everybody some of the Corinthians were
thinking everybody died and it was over
with and he's saying what good is
baptism so yeah no nobody should be
baptized in behalf of someone else
that's dead I know they do that in the
uh latterday saint church but I think
they misin at this verse you know we got
a book talking about baptism it's called
baptism is it really necessary we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and ask the number is 800 835 6747 you
can ask for the book it's called baptism
is it really necessary you can dial
pound 250 on your smartphone say Bible
answers live and ask for the book
baptism is it really necessary we'll be
happy to send it to you if you're in
Canada or the us otherwise go to our
website if you're outside of North
America and you can read it right there
at the Amazing Facts website MH we've
got Britney listening in California
Britney welcome to the program hey yeah
my question is was Joseph of er MAA a
Christian before the death and
resurrection of Christ or after all
right great well I think that when
Joseph he was sort of like a secret
follower up until the time of the
crucifixion and you might say at that
point he pretty much came out of the
closet when he went and talked to
Pontius pilot
and said I want the body of Jesus and
then he gave Jesus his own tomb and he
professed Christ he not only did that I
think that he and Nicodemus paid for the
burial materials or most of it the women
went to get some and came back Sunday
morning so uh I'd say that even before
the resurrection uh right about the time
of the C crucifixion he kind of came out
but he had been uh along with Nicodemus
and maybe some others they had been
believing and feeling sympathy for the
teachings of Christ and that he might be
the Messiah and I think at the time that
he died Joseph uh uh was converted what
do you think Pastor Ross that makes
sense yeah absolutely I'm just looking
for the verse where it talks in Acts
that after the resurrection uh in the
early church it says that there were
even some priests that were converted
yeah I think it's chapter five chapter
five of acts so there were quite a few
even those in high positions that
recognized Christ as being the Messiah
and accepted him and here we have an
example with Joseph arthy and you
mentioned Nicodemus which we read about
right in John chapter 3 right the very
beginning of his ministry all right
thank you Britany we've got James in
Tennessee James welcome to the
program hey good evening pastors love
all that y'all do how are y'all today
doing great thank you James doing great
I was just saying I've always went by
the Bible and the Bible only and I read
your name of God book but I always
trying to keep the Ten Commandments like
the first and second is the sepher got
any biblical values to it cuz I know
it's got the book of mccabes in it and
it had the Old and New Testament in it
it's a separate of any like biblical
values today and and in it it says the
father and son's name was yahu and the
son's name was yahusha if I'm not
mistaken is there any reference to that
the safer to the Bible is it holy any
holy meaning yeah well the Bible says
first of all I think you're quoting from
one of what they call an apocryphal book
these are some books that uh they may be
in some of the Orthodox Bibles but uh
most Protestants uh do not have them in
their Bibles because they don't
recognize them as authoritative and part
of the Canon but to the bigger question
you know God's name is certainly holy
there's been quite a bit of debate in
recent years how do you say the sacred
name of God when God told Moses you know
I'll be known by this name of Jehovah
and or the I am that I am and then some
have translated the sacred name of um of
God as Yahweh uh there there were no um
uh vowels it was just
consonants and um oh wait am I getting
that right yeah and um they uh they
didn't know exactly how to pronounce it
because the the Jews would C of sort of
use a secret code name for the Lord
they'd make it generic whenever that
name came up because they thought it was
too sacred to utter it and the correct
pronunciation is a mystery now
because you know there's no recordings
of how it was said but people shouldn't
fixate on that because God actually uses
many names in the Bible it wasn't just
Jehovah he's called Elohim the El Shai
and you look in Revelation and I think
there's like 25 different names for
Jesus everything from the Alpha and
Omega to the beginning the I am he's
called The Living Water the the bread of
life the Good Shepherd the
door um the son of righteousness that
arises with healing in his wings you go
through the Bible and the different
names that God gives
himself um I I don't think that the Lord
Cuts us off from praying if we do not
pronounce a particular name in the
original tongue you know it's
interesting when Jesus gave the example
to the disciples when they asked him
teach us how to pray uh and Jesus said
when you pray say our father in Heaven
he didn't say you need to mention a
specific name of God right but you
understand that God is our father and we
pray to him we have a book it's called
the names of God and uh we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks the number for that is
8835 6747 and the book is called the
names of God you can also dial pound 250
say Bible answers live and ask for the
book and we'll be happy to send it to
you if you're in North America Thanks
James we've got Anna in orgon Anna
welcome to the
program evening pastors
evening my question is about the last
words of Jesus on the
cross so from Matthew
2746 and Mark
15:34 they're the same but John 1930
they're different I was wondering why
they're different that's a good question
and you know it is something of a
mystery um I did a message several years
ago on the last last words of a dying
man and I went through these seven
statements that Jesus makes from the
cross and when I went back and forth
between Matthew Mark and John and even
Luke um I came to the conclusion of of
many others that Jesus final words were
it is finished father into your hands I
commit my spirit says saying this he
breathed his
last so you know earlier he said I
thirst uh earlier he said you know Elo
Elo lakani my God my God why have you
forsaken me but I think the final words
were um it is finished father into your
hands I commend my spirit because then
it says and he breathed is in saying
this he breathed his last but several of
the words happened in quick succession
when he said I thirst they gave him the
vinegar it say he tasted it and then he
made this statement it's like that was
the last thing he did so does that make
sense uh
Anna yes yeah
absolutely thank you all right hey
thanks so much appreciate your call you
know Pastor I I think one of the reasons
we have four gospels is each of them you
they obviously read the other gospels
they knew and it there some of them John
one of the oldest of the gospels well
you know what there's one thing he said
as well I was there I heard it I was
standing at the foot of the cross right
at the foot of the cross put that in
there it is finished so it's kind of a
fuller broader explanation so it covers
everything that Jesus said and John was
standing there by Mary when Jesus said
woman Behold thy son son Behold thy
mother
and he kind of committed the care of his
mother to the Apostle John so he wanted
to make sure and include that yeah it's
in there all right great next quter that
we have is Anthony listening in New York
Anthony welcome to the
program hello Pastor Doug and Pastor
Ross um hi I uh uh my question is based
on Hebrews chapter 8 verse five um where
it says that uh where where God told
Moses to uh make the temple according to
the pattern that was shown him on the
mountain and I've always wondered well
what does that PN what does the pattern
look like in the heaven the the
sanctuary but then I read in um John CH
2 verse 19 through 21 and it Jesus say
destroyed this Temple and in three days
I will raise it up and then verse 21 it
says that it was talking about his body
and then in Revelation CH 21: 20 I'm
sorry uh 21 verse 22 it says uh and I
it's talking about the holy city it says
I saw Temple therein for the Lord God
Almighty and the lamb are the Temple of
it so I just want to just know your
thoughts on what do you is there
anything we can take away from this to
understand that the what the pattern of
the temple um excuse me look like in
heaven well you know there is a temple
in heaven now because Jesus is there
interceding as our high priest as far as
the exact dimensions of it um you know I
think that the Earthly Temple was a
miniature of the dwelling place of God
I'm sure the dwelling place of God in
heaven is infinitely greater than the
you know 70E 75 or 100 ft that the
Earthly Temple was Solomon's Temple was
bigger than the one that they had in the
wilderness and then the Third Temple
that was built by Ezra and Nehemiah it
was a little smaller in Dimensions than
Solomon's but I think it had a bigger
porch or bigger acreage so um but when
it says there's no no temple in it there
is a Dwelling Place of God in heaven
talks about his throne there is no
Temple that is built around a
sacrificial system because Christ is our
sacrifice sin is forever done away with
and there's no need for that thoughts on
that absolutely you know it's
interesting during the 10,000 years with
the redeemed or in heaven you have a
reference to the temple the 144,000
talks about the being in the temple but
when sin and Sinn is are no more at the
end of the Thousand Years and the Earth
is recreated then it is that you get a
reference ref to there was no Temple
therein for the lamb is the temple well
the purpose of the sanctuary the purpose
of the temple had met its fulfillment
sin and sinners were no more all things
were reconciled and made complete so the
Heavenly Sanctuary exists in that
fashion as a sanctuary until the Plan of
Redemption is made its fulfillment right
then there's no need for that phase of
the sanctuary so that's why John says I
saw no Temple therein MH very good hey
hope that helps a little bit that's a a
great question Anthony and we have a
book that talks about God drew the plan
that's right it's one of our amazing
fact study guides we'll be happy to send
it to anyone wanting to learn more about
the sanctuary the number to call is 800
835 6747 you can ask for the study guide
It's called God drew the plans or do
pound 250 on your smart phone and say
Bible answers live and say God drew the
plans that's the name of the the study
guide and we will send it to you yeah
you'll be blessed friends we're going to
take a brief break we're just at the
halfway point uh there's more to come
call with your Bible questions and we'll
get back and do our best to answer them
from the word in just a few
[Music]
moments stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly are you looking for a simple way
to share your faith if you've ever found
yourself Tongue Tied when trying to
explain what the Bible teaches about the
Sabbath the second coming or the
afterlife you'll love the new amazing
fact tracks these colorful tracks
feature easy to read type and are large
enough to grab everyone's attention but
small enough to fit in your pocket to
carry with you wherever you
go 11 key Bible teachings are available
now purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save equip yourself and your church
to reach your community with the
eye-catching amazing fact tracks amazing
fact tracks easy to read easy to share
to order your sample bundle call
8005382583
God the Bible say God is one God but is
he three persons is Jesus also Eternal
God because Jesus is the son of God does
that mean there was a time when he did
not exist or he was brought into
existence is the holy spirit a person or
is he just the force and the energy that
God uses to communicate you know I
thought this was so important I really
felt led of the Lord to write a book on
the subject called exploring the Trinity
one God or three in this book we answer
those very important question questions
we talk about the history of the holy
spirit in the Old Testament as well as
the history of the holy spirit in the
church and how it has been much debated
this is something we really need to
understand because Jesus said eternal
life comes from knowing
[Music]
god you're listening to Bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of God and
his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for get practical answers about
the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and we're doing our
best to answer your Bible questions if
you call in live with your questions and
that number to call in is 800 God says
it's 800
7297 and my name is Doug Bachelor my
name is John Ross and we would like to
just greet our friends Pastor Doug we
have folks who are listening across the
country on landbased radio stations but
also listening on the internet in one of
the very popular sites that people are
listening to Bible aners live is
pray.com and uh we want to greet all of
those of you who are listening on
pray.com as well as in Colorado KS YF
radio station so welcome to the program
and uh if you have a question call in
we'd love to hear from you our next
caller that we have is Gina listening in
California Gina welcome to L's
life thank you hello pastors please my
question comes from Revelation 2:17 he
who has an ear let him hear what the
spirit says to the churches to him who
overcomes I will give some of the Hidden
Mana to eat and I will give him a white
stone and on the stone a new name
written which no one knows except him
who receives it please I've heard that
the new name will be based on our
personality but please um how come we
will be the only on that knows the new
name well and Pastor Ross may want to
add to this but uh I think that we have
a personal experience with the Lord that
is unique and so there'll be some name
that um you know we only understand when
it says we don't know we're the only
ones who really knows it means we really
are the only ones who know the depth of
what that means you know Jesus gave a
new name to uh Peter he was Simon he
called him Peter what are your thoughts
yeah absolutely let me first say
something about the white stone and the
black stone that's kind of neat there
was an ancient custom uh familiar back
in in the Roman times where if a jury um
found somebody innocent of some crime or
you know they were accused of a crime
but they were acquitted they would given
a white stone if somebody was found
guilty they would give a black stone
well here you have Jesus saying I'll
give him a white stone meaning they SS a
forgiven they acquitted and of course
the name is a reference to character and
it says nobody knows their name but the
one who receives it so there is a
relationship that we each have
individually with God God knows our
heart he knows our characters and when
he gives us that new name is going to
remind us of some Deliverance that he
has provided for us individually amen
and uh that's the significance of the
white stone with the name all right well
thank you very much hope that helps a
little bit Gina next caller that we have
is junith listening in Nevada junith
welcome to the
program hello good evening Pastor dog
and Pastor John
R my question is uh what does God say in
the Bible about one save is not always
saved thank you yeah appreciate your
call junith um there are a lot of dear
Christians mostly from the Protestant
faith that believe and it's really based
on John Calvin now John Calvin was a
great Protestant reformer but he I think
misunderstood some of the teachings of
Paul on predestination
Peter said there are some things that
Paul says that are hard to be understood
and I think that was one of the things
and the idea being that God had
pre-selected who was going to be saved
and once you are saved you can't be lost
well the Bible has a number of
statements including right here in
Revelation where Jesus said you know
unless you repent I'll take its
Candlestick out of its place Peter talks
about those who are once washed but they
turned back to wallowing in the mire
like a dog that turns to its again he
talks about people that were saved
Hebrews chapter a chapter um six where
he said for it's impossible once a
person has tasted the Heavenly gift if
they be turned away to renew them again
now what that verse means requires some
explanation but one thing is very clear
there are people who were in a knowing
relationship with the Lord and they turn
away from it and then you have examples
like a Judas who was an apostle casting
out devils and and you know following
Jesus and grieved away the Holy Spirit
and say Satan entered him King Saul was
chosen by the Lord filled with the
spirit even says he was a prophet at one
point but he began to Rebel over the
years became proud grieved away the Holy
Spirit killed the priest went to a witch
and he died lost so the idea that once
you're saved you lose your freedom to
choose is not taught anywhere in the
Bible we don't God doesn't take away our
freedom to choose to turn away we got a
book it's called K saved man choose to
be lost it talks about the lot of
scripture in there that's good and we'll
be happy to send it again to anyone who
calls and ask the number is 8835
6747 ask for the book can a saved man
choose to be lost you can also get up by
dialing pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible answers live and then ask for the
book can a saved man choose to be lost
and I you know Pastor Ross I really
recommend that if there's anyone out
there that is a little bit fuzzy on that
subject you should ask for that book cuz
the book is it's really powerful it's
written by Joe Cruz very easy to read
full of scripture because it's dangerous
for a person to think they're saved if
they're not that's what Jesus said many
will come to him in the Judgment say
Lord Lord we cast out Devils did
wonderful Works taught in your name
he'll say I don't know you so if you're
thinking well I came to the altar when I
was 10 years old and I was saved but I'm
not really living for Jesus now but once
I'm saved I can't be lost that's a
dangerous belief and maybe on the other
side of true too people who feel like
I'm so bad there's no way I can be saved
I must be predestined to be lost that's
right it'll also give them y absolutely
next caller that we have is Lori
listening in Michigan Lori welcome to
the
program hi Pastor Doug Pastor Ross I was
reading in Isaiah 6 um this morning and
I come across between um the ninth
chapter and the 13th chapter and I was
wanting to find out when was this
supposed to take place well chapter 6
begins with him explaining his
conversion experience saying in the year
that King Isiah died I saw the Lord and
then you know he feels he's no wor not
worthy and says a wo is me and God
forgives him and says who will I send
and he kind of accepts the role of
prophet and then God says go tell this
people and then as you read in the
following chapters he's got several
chapters with a message for Israel and
this is during the time of uh ahaz and
Hezekiah and um uh I think even is it uh
Amos anyway Manasseh ultimately the son
of Hezekiah killed him so Isaiah
prophesied during the time of three
kings actually I think it tells us that
yeah in the first verse during the days
of Isaiah jotham ahaz and Hezekiah Four
Kings and of course he prophesied
shortly before Jerusalem was conquered
by the Babylonians right but that that
was still about 60 years away right from
that time but um so the messages you're
reading in those chapters he's kind of
calling them out for their Disobedience
so is that answering what you're asking
no actually what I was asking is from
verse 9 to verse 13 of chapter 6 um of
chapter six yeah I think I thought you
were going from chapter nine okay I'm
sorry so he says go tell this people
keep on hearing but do not understand
keep seeing but do not perceive make the
heart of this people dull and their ears
heavy and shut their eyes at the
part yeah that you're wondering about
yeah uh God is not you God does not want
people to be
lost um I think the Lord is saying that
you continue talking to them and they
don't listen they ultimately grieve away
the spirit and through his preaching as
they continue contined to resist their
hearts became hard so in that sense you
could say your preaching is just as they
continue to refuse and stop their ears
are hardening their hearts and then also
if you look in verse 11 I find it
interesting he asked the question he
says how long how long is he to prophesy
and the answer comes back until the
cities are laid waste without
inhabitants and the houses without a man
and the land is utterly desolate well
that was a prophecy that as we mentioned
uh really met its fulfillment just some
60 70 years later with the destruction
of Jerusalem so Isaiah was a prophet
providing warning to the inhabitants of
Jerusalem and to the Jews that judgment
was coming so it's all in that context
and it talks about a tenth being or a
tenth will return it talks about those
who's uh like a tree that's cut down and
the stump remains uh so a Remnant will
return back to Jerusalem and of course
that happened after the 7 years of
Babylonian captivity so that's kind of
the context I think that's been referred
to there in those verses yeah and Jesus
even quotes that very verse in in from
Isaiah when he said these people have
ears but they don't hear they have eyes
but they don't see they don't understand
lest I should heal them and forgive them
so he wanted to have them
listen thank you appreciate that Lori
hope that helps a little bit we've got
Henry listening in New York hry Henry
welcome to the program uh yes good
evening past my question is no it took
129 to look at uh God took God took two
of each animal what did he have room
enough there for the
whales yeah well when it says that God
took two of each animal it's talking
about animals that were living on the
land uh he didn't need to put sea
creatures in the ark because uh you know
they survive just fine in the water I'm
Sur I'm just absolutely amazed every
year we see the Creeks around our place
up in the mountains flood they full of
rocks and mud and I think there's fish
in there how do the fish
survive and when the water settles down
here are the fish I'm going how' they
live through that all that mud breathing
that mud and the Rocks going and the
torren of water and somehow they I don't
know how they did it but um I think some
sea creatures probably did die out in
the flood but most of them whales in
particular they just go to the surface
and breathe so one that have to breathe
through their gills I would think it'd
be really tough on so no uh no sea
creatures he didn't have a little bowl
with goldfish inside the ark right all
right thank you Henry we got Aaron
listening in New York Aaron welcome to
the program good evening pastors evening
I was reading the comments in the chat
box on the YouTube live stream of this
very show and I saw this question that I
would like you to respond on this very
show the question is did Jesus raise
himself from the grave or did God the
father raised him by calling
him yeah that's a uh that's a very uh
important and it can be a confusing
question because Jesus does say in one
place I have power to lay my life down
and I have power to raise it up that's
John 10:17 thank you yeah so how could
someone that is dead raise thems because
by virtue of being
dead it's hard to you know not anything
yeah it's like waking yourself up
without an alarm and some people can do
it but um I I think when Jesus say I
have power to raise it up the word you
know Jesus prophesied seven several
times he said I will rise the third day
the very word that he spoke his
prophecies never failed and so because
Christ is one with the father it was you
know the father that of course I think
called him forth but um that's something
of a mystery I don't know what are your
thoughts yeah you know I I think you
used an illustration it's probably good
of sleep um you know you can't wake
yourself up per se but somebody can wake
you up you still have to wake yourself
up but they called you and you wake up
yeah so some have seen it or Illustrated
as the father calls the Son and the son
arises mhm so yes Jesus had power to
raise himself up but the father called
him the angel came down rolled away the
stone and called Christ and he rose from
the dead yeah that's a good answer I
hope that helps a little bit Aaron and
you can U share that with the friends on
the chat there all right thank you Erin
next caller that we have is Brad
listening in Tennessee Brad welcome to
the program he P thank you so much
appreciate your program thanks Brad
appreciate you're calling in this is my
question for tonight uh with all the
recent talk in the US government about
seeing lights in the sky going foring
military pilot what does the Bible say
about also I know Pastor Doug pilot I
was wondering if you had
there okay you're cutting your voice is
cutting out a little bit but I think
you're asking um you know what do I what
does the Bible say about the UFOs and
have I ever seen as a pilot a UFO second
part of the question I'll answer first
uh a UFO is an unidentified flying
object and there's other words and terms
I use but have I ever seen one yes um
and I remember seeing one flying with
Karen I said look this is a flying
saucer there's this red Flying Saucer
and I just couldn't resist getting
closer to find out what it was and and
someone had released a red myar you know
those myar balloons are kind of they
they look metallic but it wasn't a
regular round balloon it was floating in
the saucer shape and and I I started
flying over and I thought oh man it's a
balloon but in the sun when the sun hit
it it looked much bigger and I I thought
it was a flying saucer but um yeah I was
surprised that even during one of the
recent Republican debates someone was
fed at a question about UFOs he kind of
resented that they gave him that
question but um it it has been in the
news lately I you know I don't think I
do believe there's intelligent life on
other planets I don't think there's any
doubt about that you know certainly we
know God has angels and there's unfallen
angels and Revelation talks about you
know through Christ God made the worlds
actually that's Hebrews
1:2 but um and I think also in
Colossians it says that there are other
beings but I don't think that the
unfallen worlds are being allowed to
interact with our world because we've
got this disease of sin the only people
involved in our planet are the hospital
staff that would be God the father son
Spirit and the angels and once we're
redeemed from sin I think we'll be able
to interact with unfallen beings again
or holy beings but and of course the
devil has access to the Earth yeah and
he might you know he's a deceiver from
the beginning it might serve his ends to
make it appear as though there's some
intelligent life or flying Source or
whatever it might be but um yeah as you
he's an angel of Light he can cause
deception he can bring fire down from
heaven right so yeah I think a lot of
these sightings some of them are just
common
misunderstandings some of them may be
spiritual deception mhm says in the last
days three unclean spirits like frogs
where is that Revelation 16 come out of
the mouth of the Beast the dragon the
false prophet and they go forth and do
Miracles so I don't I don't know flying
saucers of the Miracles they do or UFOs
but there is going to be deception
that's right okay thank you Brad we've
got um Cedric listening in Florida
Cedric welcome to the program thank you
pastors how you doing tonight much
better than we
deserve I have a question for you and
it's based on revelation 22 okay and the
second
verse regarding the Tree of Life
M says in the middle of its Street on
either side of the river there was the
Tree of
Life yes so how can you have the tree of
life but it's on both sides of the
river no no my question is that there is
probably more than one tree of
life well you know it's always referred
to in the singular in the Old Testament
and the New Testament so the way some
Scholars have understood that is this is
an enormous tree I mean we live in
California where we've got trees that
are you know almost 400t tall this is an
enormous tree that has its um it goes
down on both sides of the river and its
branches grow together above the river
so it's almost like the river runs
through it and it's got 12 different
kinds of fruit so this tree is an
extraordinary tree and I know people are
thinking well that's kind of hard to
imagine well that's good because Paul
said that you can't even imagine the
things that God has prepared but it's
really clear the word there is a
singular tree it's not plural in Greek
or in the Hebrew but it's on both sides
of the river and it's got 12 different
kinds of fruit in this verse He said
Each Tree of Life which bore 12 fruits
you know yeah you maybe I can add to
that if you if you look at the king J
I'm looking at the new King James if you
look at the word tree it is in italic so
the italic ver the words that you see in
the Bible they were added by the
translators for context so if you read
it without that it would say each
yielding its fruit every month so it's
talking about the tree of life that
reaches on either side of the river and
each side is bearing its fruit every
month the word their tree was added just
for context okay yeah so it's it's a
singular
tree yeah yeah the first word tree that
you find there is singular yes but I I I
let me ask a question in the new Earth
new Heaven and new earth where you have
probably millions of redeemed will it be
okay to have just one tree of life yeah
if the tree is big enough and if you
don't have to eat from it every day Adam
ate from the Tree of Life you know Adam
ate from the Tree of Life a few times
and it kept him going for 900 years
that's right and you know it talks about
12 different kinds of fruit it talks
about all the redeemed coming up and
gathering in the New Jerusalem every
month and every Sabbath well every month
you go and try a different kind of fruit
on the tree so it's a big tree as I said
eyes not seen uh ear hasn't heard
Nei they entered into the heart of man
the things that God is preparing for
those that love him all right thank you
Cedric good question uh we're ready with
our next caller sha he's listening from
Michigan sha welcome to the
program thank you so much my question is
from Deuteronomy
2211 which says Thou shalt not wear a
garment of diverse sorts as of Woolen
and linen together and I didn't know if
that only applied at the time that it
was written
uh and to Israel as a nation or if it
still applies today and how we could
know yeah well I you know I think that
he says this also in context of several
other Commandments well for one thing if
you um are wearing you know one is a
vegetable and one is an animal wool
comes from an animal linen comes from a
plant they do not wash and wear the same
they do not shrink and warm the same and
uh then he goes on and he says you're
not to you know you're not to hook a
donkey and an oxen together they're two
different animals and they're going to
pull differently and then you know he
also talks about that uh people should
not be having intimate relationships
with animals but um if you uh sew a
patch of linen on a wool garment it's
just going to tear it out they don't
match they don't mix and I think that's
the point I don't I I can't think of
anything we wear today that's a combin
ation of wool and linen they we still
don't mix them in together just from
practical reasons and also I think if
you read the whole context of the
chapter uh God is making a distinction
between the dress and the Traditions uh
of the Jews to the other nations that
were around them now I don't know if the
other nations mix these different
Fabrics together but it talks about uh
not making cuting in your flesh for the
dead it talks about not shaving their
heads the way the the pagans did the
Nations around them so God wanted them
to be modest in their dress and also to
have a distinction they were different
they were his people and they were
different from the Nations there in
Israel while surrounding Israel Glenn
Ohio welcome to the
program thank you for taking my call
yeah and my question concerns the
scripture that's very popular and that
is 2 Corinthians 58 where Paul says that
he would rather be absent from the body
and presence of the Lord I know many
Christian churches use that as very
verification that when you die a
Christian you go to heaven but Paul did
not say to be absent from the body is to
be present with the Lord the key word is
rather he said I would rather be absent
from the body and presence with the Lord
and that includes a whole bunch of us
wondered if how you folks felt about
that well I agree I I think that uh you
know Paul is making a comparison here
but for a Believer if you die you sleep
until the resurrection ction but you
have no consciousness of time so the
next thought is the Resurrection The
Bible's pretty clear that the dead in
Christ rise at the return of the Lord
not before that and Jesus said to uh um
Mary and Martha that they said oh we
know he'll rise up the last day so they
were all clear the resurrection was in
the last day the day of the Lord the
second coming for a Believer when you
die and you're absent from the body your
next conscious thought is the
resurrection so you know I can Comfort
people when they say well he's with the
Lord now and I'll say well he's not not
yet but for for him if a person dies
yeah their next conscious thought is the
resurrection but it hasn't happened yet
the Bible is pretty clear that those
that are in the graves will hear his
voice and come forth when he returns and
that has not happened yet so what would
the point be of a resurrection and a
judgment if people are already in heaven
mhm and of course we have a study guide
on the subject it's called are the Dead
really dead and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 8835
6747 you can ask for that study guide
It's called either dead really dead or
do pound 250 on your phone say Bible
answers live and ask for that study
guide are the Dead really dead do we
have time for one more Pastor D we can
try real quick Ruth in Arizona we have
about a minute uh what's your question
good evening Pastor Ross and Pastor Doug
our question is we've been reading uh
Revelation 11 is it talking about the
two witnesses and if so is it Moses and
Elijah well a lot of people I'm sorry go
ahead and Will are they going to be
coming down to earth before Jesus
comes as well yeah thank you no the two
witnesses are a symbol of Moses and
Elijah Moses and Elijah are in heaven
they've got their reward they're
mentioned in Mark chapter 9 they are not
coming down on to the Earth and dying
again Moses represents the Law Elijah
represents the prophets we've actually
got a free book we'll send you it's
called the two witnesses in the Glorious
Mount if you call in we'll send that to
you but we're out of time for this
segment of our Bible questions now let
me explain if you've not heard this
before we have an unusual ending for our
program because we have satellite
listeners around the country they're on
a different clock than our landbased
stations and so we sign off with our
satellite friends and tell them Oro till
next week everyone else stay tuned
Pastor Ross and I are coming back in
just a couple of minutes we're going to
take your rapid fire Bible questions
that you've sent to us via email for all
the rest God bless until we study again
next
week thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back again to Bible answers live we want
to thank all of those who emailed us
your Bible question if you'd like to
send us a Bible question via email it's
just B questions at
amazingfacts.org that's B questions
amazingfacts.org pass it out here's the
first one came from Cape Town South
Africa I know that place quite well it's
where you were born that's right and the
question is uh is Satan the scapegoat
describ in Leviticus chapter 16 uh after
all it says both goats needed to be
blemish free well every creature that
was brought to the sanctuary needed to
be blemish free because it was a holy
environment but the question is what's
the significance on the day of atonement
there was two goats one goat is called
the Lord's goat it doesn't say both
goats were called the Lord's goat so
right away that means the other goat is
not the Lord's goat and um one dies for
sin that's the Lord's goat which is a
symbol of Jesus the other one does not
die it's not sacrificed the sins of the
people for the year are placed on that
goat it's taken away from the sanctuary
and it's released in the wilderness by a
fit man that's been understood by many
and I'm one of those that this is a
symbol how ultimately the guilt and
responsibility of all sin Jesus does not
bear sins forever says he's coming
without sin uh the second time U the
ultimate responsibility is going to fall
on the devil and um you know he's often
pictured even as a goat uh so we think
this other goat the scapegoat is the
devil and the Lord's goat is the lord
they're not both the Lord's goats okay
great next question that we have Do's
asking uh is it wrong to
gamble yeah the Bible says do not make
haste to be rich and the idea of getting
rich quick is um something wrong with
that anything that's addictive is not
good some people are addicted to
gambling and it their whole lives
implode I would never recommend gambling
for a Christian okay next question why
does the New Jerusalem need walls and
Gates is there anything bad outside well
at first it says the wicked attack the
city of God in Revelation 20 but no the
walls are not only to keep things out
the walls are sometimes a border it just
shows Within These precincts is going to
be the dwelling place of the redeem so
it just represents a border through
eternity nothing to fear we'll be able
to fly over the walls okay next question
we have uh this one's interesting it
says I've received different answers
every time I ask some questions if
everyone's going by the Bible why does
one Pastor answer differently from
another cuz some are right and some are
wrong hey friends we are out of time
good point to end on we hope we're
telling you the truth it's based on the
Bible we'll study again together next
week bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions